oh
i welcome those who have just joined we
would be starting in more 10 minutes at
the scheduled time
it would be great in the meantime if you
all could tell about yourself in the
chat box about your uh educational
background and what makes you join the
webinar today what excites you about
space omix and
what do you expect from today's webinar
right
hello everyone i welcome those who have
just joined we would be starting in more
three to four minutes we are waiting for
everyone else to join as well and i
request you all that when you join
please keep your mic on mute and when
you have any question please raise your
hand or put in the chat box we'll be
happy to answer them thank you
hello everyone i would like to welcome
you all for the webinar today on a very
exciting topic space omix that is
dedicated to the study of omix data to
study molecular mechanisms affected by
space travel and is critical for
astronaut health
so astrobiology is a science which
addresses the origin of life on earth
and potential for life elsewhere in the
universe
space flight is one of the most extreme
conditions encountered by humans
advances in
methodologies especially genomics
transcriptomics proteomics and
metabolomics have revealed that unique
differences exist between individuals
these differences can be amplified in
extreme conditions such as space flight
a better understanding of individual
differences may allow us to develop
personalized countermeasure packages
that optimize the safety and performance
of each astronaut
radiation micro
[Music]
gravity
altered atmospheric gas composition
isolation and diet changes as well are
just some of the known stressors
affecting humans in the space
environment with extended mission
durations and distances outside of
earth's orbit these factors are expected
to increase
there are several adverse human health
effects associated with space flight
including bone demineralization skeletal
muscle atrophy cardiovascular
deconditioning
vestibular control immune system
suppression and also neuro ocular
ailments it is critical to understand
how space flight factors affect human
health in order to develop safe and
effective counter measures
the nasa twin study catalyzed the need
for more comprehensive consortium-based
approaches to study the long-term
effects of space flight on humans here
nine research groups studied a single
data type in detail vist another group
performed multi-organic synthesis to
determine the whole body changes the
study identified alterations in numerous
data types including telomere length
gene regulation gut microbiome
composition body weight carotid artery
dimensions and serum metabolite profiles
before we start with the talk i would
want to introduce us we are a u.s based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioware informatics more accessible
omixlogic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
omixlogic is an international program
that is running in five different
regions with over 10 000 users around
the world and due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
my name is sunali curry and i am the
omixlogic community manager i am
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users that are a part of a
bioinformatics community managed by pine
biotech
our training is designed to allow
participants to apply methods to curated
and new data sets and develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learnt in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects
together with our existing modules for
which you will get access to the
omixlogic portal where you can try and
explore these modules exercises and
pipeline building coding and various
methods of analysis using projects
resources from peer-reviewed
publications
to begin with we would introduce you all
to our very basic introductory and
insightful course that is bytes and
molecules this course is intended for
all
those interested in understanding how
the current revolution in biomedical
data impacts biomedical research and
human health you would find introductory
lessons on various comics fields and
also on fields like precision medicine
are an introduction to space omics and
astronaut health
finally we will introduce our new and
plant specializations like the field of
astrobiology
that is captivating the minds of
students who are seeing the commercial
space industry developed before their
eyes
as a part of all the omics logic
training programs students and
researchers developed their research
proposals and worked on independent
research projects as well to analyze
publicly available omics data to address
pressing questions in spaceonics and
astrobiology
we will today discuss about few of such
projects by delara dicken who worked on
radiation threats to humans in space an
alternative approach with probiotics and
sribrijit paruva who worked on
transcriptomic analysis of dna damage
response in zebrafish embryos under
simulated microgravity
we will today also hear from them
we also recently had a wonderful talk by
professor shiradatta
at university of maryland school of
medicine institute of marine and
environmental technology the topic of
his talk was earth's extremophiles and
the search for life on mars
please find the link of this
extraordinary talk in the chat box you
uh you can go there and have a look
we will today also review the schedule
of the sessions for the programs which
is scheduled from october 19th till
november
15th and now i would like to welcome our
speakers and mentors for the program
subrajeed barua and delara dicken
shubrachit barua is an ms in molecular
biology and biotechnology at the
international scammed laboratory itmo
university saint petersburg russia
he is a graduate of red school to a 2021
latex french oxo biology society he is
an astrobiology educator at art of
inquiry where he works closely with
julia brodsky former nasa iss astronaut
trainer he is also a volunteer at mars
on earth project where he works on
martian projects he is a russian
government open door scholar and a
president scholarship awardee as well
he was also one of the top 10 students
globally selected for sgac space health
symposium london 2021
uh we are uh pleased to have you with us
today
subscribe that was a wonderful
introduction to
me as well as the entire topic of space
omics
and
astronaut health which we are going to
talk today
hello everyone it's amazing to see you
all here today
i'm
ready to go and talk to you about this
amazing field of
informatics
it's a
since we are depending on technology a
lot
yeah my computer already shows me that
my internet is unstable it would be
great if you can write down in the chat
section if you can hear me well if you
can see me at my presentation so if you
can see the presentation and listen to
my voice clearly please write one or a
plus sign in the chat section that will
be a confirmation to me that we are
ready to go
ah subrajee can you switch off your
video maybe if you switch off your video
your voice would be clear
sure sure that's fine i'll do that
all right so i can see a lot of
texts in the chat box as well so i think
we are good to go so
welcome everyone to introduction to
space omix
and this presentation this webinar will
be focused on understanding space health
through omix i will talk about what
omics is
what is this
theme or this branch of science all
about what are the various opportunities
where early career scientists as i would
like to say
would get an opportunity to do some
hands-on
how we are providing an opportunity to
start your own project in the domain of
space omics
and
a lot is there to talk about so without
any further ado
let's move on
to today's webinar
so
i'm pretty much sure that
all of you present here today has been
inspired by this
extraordinary field of science which is
space science
be it the first
person in space yuri gagarin
or the milestone event
that is the landing of human on the moon
by neil armstrong and edwin aldrin
or maybe the recent commercial launches
like bob and doug on spacex
or the other space tourism-based flights
these are all our inspiration and that
was the exact name of the recent
commercial flight as well where people
those who are not astronauts
went to space so this is an exciting
time to be enthusiastic about space
science in general
and according to statistics
around 20 percent of the kids
worldwide have a dream of becoming an
astronaut
so i'm pretty sure that many people who
are present today in the audience once
in their lifetime have definitely dreamt
about becoming an astronaut
i would admit i have done the same
but
as we grew up we took different branches
of science went on to study different
specialization and somehow that dream of
ours kind of faded away me being an
biologist
never thought that i can be a part of
space science or the space industry in
any form but here we are the new domain
of space science astrobiology has made
my dream possible and today we are going
to talk about how
you can also begin your journey as an
astrobiologist or a space space omix
specialist
whenever you look up into the night sky
see these brilliant stars the brilliant
planets
i'm pretty much sure you must have
wondered if we are alone in this
universe are we the only place where
life can exist or there might be some
place far away in the distance maybe
millions of light years away
there's someone waving at us
we don't know with the scientific
advancements that we have had over the
past years
we have only found one planet that has
life on it and that's our very own
planet earth
the blue marvel as it is seen from space
above the only planet in the entire
universe to our knowledge so far where
life can sustain and thrive harmoniously
but
in the recent times
there has been debates and talks and
speculations about other planets being
host to various life forms or maybe
they've had life forms
many years ago mars our neighboring red
planet is one of them for sure and
recently in the year 2020 nasa launched
the milestone rover which was named
perseverance to mars and its sole
mission was to
study astrobiological
symptoms or signals which we also call
as biosignatures or techno signatures on
the surface of mars
the perseverance rover which you can see
here is called an astrobiology robot so
with the name you can understand its
mission is to look for potential life
forms
or
to
find out the relics of ancient life
forms
one of the major goals of perseverance
rover is to drill in the martian soil
collect the soil sample and make it
ready for a return mission so you must
be wondering what are the scientists up
to when they get the soil samples right
the soil samples back on earth now what
so that's where
our topic kicks in that is space omics
these soil samples are being brought
back to earth to analyze them through
a technique which is known as
metagenomics what is metagenomics all
about we will be talking in depth during
our one month program but in short
metagenomics is a technique of
analyzing the dna rna or any of those
nucleic acid remains in the soil samples
in the raw soil samples that's pretty
exciting i'm pretty exciting excited for
it as well so
looking forward to talking more about it
but apart from mars
there are other places as well where we
expect life to exist
one of them is jupiter's moon europa
europa is a frosty satellite it's
covered with thick layers of ice but it
has been
speculated
under scientific grounds
that underneath the thick layer of eyes
there remains liquid water just like
when the lakes freeze when you have
snowfall
but under those frozen layers of ice the
fishes can live
pretty much comfortably because the
water underneath is still warm and in
liquid form
and if that's the case if liquid is
liquid water is present on europa
doesn't that make you wonder
whether europa has some sort of aquatic
life if not
macro sized life maybe microbes and
that's the reason why nasa has planned
to send this particular
rover robot mission which is known as
the europa clipper
in the 2030s and
this is really an exciting time to be
enthusiastic about astrobiology and
space science in general because you can
witness all of these things happening
and who knows maybe one of you guys
sitting
right in the audience today could be
that person who discovers
extraterrestrial life for the first time
i'm pretty much hopeful for it
so
talking about various projects
enthusiasm
being excited about astrobiology just
like sunalika introduced in the
introductory part the lara diken is
an omixlogic research fellow she has
been working on several astrobiological
projects with us and one of our projects
was
analyzing the radiation threat on the
gut microbiome of astronauts
so
now i would like to
transfer the stage to her so that she
can share
her experience her journey of becoming
an astrobiological scientist
how did she get excited and what
motivated her to take that extra step
from being an enthusiast
to transition into someone who is
actively working in this domain
so what was her motivation
and what are the benefits that she
experiences being an active astrobiology
scientist let's hear it from her so de
lara
over to you now
thank you
great
subscribe
and it was quite an introduction
uh let me quickly share my screen
i hope everyone can see
yeah we can
see so
i'll give a quick introduction to
astrobiology and why it is important and
then i'll be talking about my personal
experiences as well
so why is it important to everyone let's
start from that one of the most
important factors is that it helps us
understand evolution better and
currently we are looking as registered
for bias signatures in outer space and
these include fossils or any other
chemicals that are residues of living
organisms
if we do find signs of life or water
in space this will help us gauge how
earth is going to evolve going into the
future and we can better adapt to it
another reason space studies are
crucial is because a lot of equipment we
use
on a daily basis is an extension of the
equipment that was invented for space
missions
some examples include artificial limbs
insulin pumps cat scans baby formula and
car fighting equipment but of course
it's not limited to these
um the challenging conditions presented
for space missions has forced us to be
more creative and gave a boost to our
daily lives as well
and last but not least we should be
excited about astrobiology because the
space travel age is observing novel
improvements and space tourism might be
available to the general public
therefore it is a field that concerns
all of us
so a little bit about my personal
experience uh it's it actually started
ideologically i just do not think that
we could be alone in this universe and
there has to be other life forms in
space that are either similar to or very
different from organisms on earth
and
also i have another connection to space
is and that is the salda lake that in
turkey and i'm turkish as well
and recently the structure of zelda lake
was compared to formations on the
surface of mars the microorganisms also
the lake used sediments and minerals in
the water to form rocks and if
similar rocks are found on mars that is
an indication that there was once water
on the surface of mars as well
i this is very exciting to me i don't
know if it's because of a biologist but
um this is quite literally a new age and
i couldn't be happier to be
living during this time to be honest
i'm also very excited about the way
inventions for space translate our daily
lives
it can help us find new treatments and
drugs for certain diseases that we
cannot
push through and find a new drug for on
earth itself
and of course there's also the fact that
it is a challenging field and i love a
good challenge
and
uh what is important to look for and is
very challenging for space studies is
habitability we have to understand what
makes our bodies and earth habitable and
we can use that to make other planets
evitable too so understanding space will
help us discover habitability factors
if we do find life forms in space like
microorganisms we can study the
disappearance of factors that cause
these microorganisms to go extinct and
hence shape the evolution of these
microbes on earth to prevent it from
happening here
so far uh since 2015 astronauts left
microbes in space in a box that is
exposed to radiation and other
extreme conditions
and they have adapted and continued to
survive so this is um actually great
news which means
even if we cannot find life in space in
the near future
and i believe that eventually we will
we know that at least we can adapt some
species to space and
they can use resources on mars to
provide oxygen and nutrition for us and
there are actually studies going on in
berman university in germany um
to study how we can adapt microbes for
outer states to give us nutrition
and why i find micro especially um
very important and um i'm very excited
about them it's because they are
everywhere and they are symbios so we
cannot live without them
and there are 55 different microbes
found on the space station
and they are
expected because we cannot live without
microbes obviously but the european
space agency has also found that these
microbes that were within the
international space station have not
evolved to be more harmful to humans or
more resistant to antibiotics however
the effect of different conditions in
space like extreme exposure to radiation
and change in diets can cause disorders
in humans and this was what my project
was based on these disorders can be
direct or indirect like the gut
microbiome affecting neural health or
the
the microbiome of the space station
affecting the skin health of astronauts
so i will be
delving more into gut microbiome when
i'm explaining my project but so far
this is it and thank you for listening
to me
thank you so much
that was a wonderful
presentation and a very good
introduction
to
astrobiology and why is it important so
now i would like to carry on from where
dilara left and she mentioned a very
important thing that is
now we are
starting to go on
space missions very frequently so as you
can see on my screen
nasa has already planned the artemis
mission that is the next human landing
mission on mars on moon
after the apollo missions
but unlike the apollo missions these
artemis missions are not going to be a
two-day affair
these astronauts are going to stay on
the surface of moon for months at least
six months
and
quite naturally the effects of this
extreme journey and this
settlement on the surface of moon is
going to have some effects on the body
of the astronauts
so
this is something which i am really
interested in looking into and
understanding more about the mechanisms
that govern these changes
also
beyond moon we are definitely going to
mars sometime maybe in the 2030s or the
2040s because as you all know this
person elon musk would be very
disappointed if we can't do that just
like he said in his quote
so
with starship
being ready at a very rapid speed
it looks very likely that human beings
would be traveling to mars
also another aspect of space travel
which has seen a huge boost in this year
itself
is space tourism
with blue origin and virgin galactic
coming into the picture of space travel
and doing some successful space tourist
missions
you can understand that now more and
more people are going to be involved in
space flight travels
be it an astronaut or be it a civilian
so it is quite the high time
to look into the problems that is faced
by the astronauts who
go to space
some of these problems are already known
to us since the days of the ablomations
that is almost 50 years ago like bone
and muscle density loss
that's the reason why the astronauts
aboard the international space station
have to indulge in rigorous exercise
daily to maintain the bone and muscle
density otherwise they lose it
at a
much much rapid speed
definitely there's physical strain
fatigue
but there are certain
molecular changes
as well
and those molecular consequences are not
visible to the naked eye you cannot see
the phenotypic changes at first but
those changes do occur like what dilara
was saying about the changes in the gut
microbiome and factors of space flight
like radiation and microgravity play a
big role in changing this cut microbiome
composition
then there's risks for cancer
development because of certain signaling
pathways being altered there can be
reproductive system issues
neurodegenerative diseases immune
response changes metabolic changes
and who knows what else there are so
many
more unexplored issues which you and me
can look into
in much more detail
so
one of the major landmarks in the study
of what happens to the human
body at a molecular level
was studied in the nasa's twin study
this was a boon to humanity because
we got
an unparalleled opportunity to study the
effects of space flight the various
factors like as i said ionizing
radiation microgravity
atmospheric temperature atmospheric
pressure composition difference
and many more
onto identical twins
these served as the best
samples that you can get because
the molecules the genes everything is
same
so the kelly brothers
scott kelly and mark kelly were involved
in this experiment and scott kelly went
to space and spend over 300 days on the
international space station whereas mark
kelly stayed on earth serving as the
ground
sample subject
after scott kelly returned to earth
as sonalika mentioned in the
introductory part there were nine
different groups who were assigned
different omics
comic studies
there were groups which focused on the
genomics the transcriptomics proteomics
metagenomics epigenomics
and there was one final group
whose duty was to integrate all the
omics and analyze the
cumulative effect on the genome of
scotch kelly and they were actually
looking into multi-omics
so at pine biotech we focus on all these
omics studies including multi-omics
and how we do it i will be showing you
in a while
but first let's talk about what were the
results what did we observe from the
twin study
so to begin with let's talk about
genomics
so
in scott kelly there was a noticeable
increase in telomere length
which
was kind of
not expected because as we know that
telomeres
should be shortened and aging is a
problem of space flight but
quite interestingly during his mission
it increased but once he returned back
on earth it shortened drastically so
this sort of observation
needs more research and understanding
similarly
talking about transcriptomics there were
various
gene pathways that were altered
various novel genes that were identified
to be affected by space flight
and
scientists are still looking into what
effects
does those alterations have on the
astronauts body
so there are
several other studies or several other
omics
results which we will talk in pretty
much detail in the program
where the we will talk about the nasa
strain study as a case study we will
take every omic
level and discuss in detail the results
the findings and the implications and
what can we do with these results in the
future how can we get involved
but
this is the time when we should mention
what
made this sort of research possible
so we are here dealing with ngs data on
next generation sequencing data
and that's how we can actually look into
the genome and the transcriptome
but this
genome sequencing was made possible by
oxford nanopore technologies min iron
which is a very small
sequencer
the size of a pen drive it can fit into
your pocket and this was taken aboard
the international space station and the
astronauts blood was drawn and sequenced
right there on the international space
station and this
technology has opened the door for a new
era of space omix which we are dealing
with in this program and also in the
upcoming one month program
now i would give you some example
of the different omics studies
based on space flights one of them is
the transcriptomic analysis of mice
and these mice were subjected to
simulations of deep space exploration
for example if you would like to go on
mars
then simulating that kind of a travel
for a longer period of time
and to see what are the effects
on the transcriptome on the gene
expression of mice
was the focus of this research group
and they found various immune system
pathways and micrornas to be
differentially expressed now what is
differential expression it is
the change in the amount of
rna that
translates into protein
under two different groups so
this sort of a change
usually has a lot of effects
and
those effects are
very fatal sometimes like they can cause
cancer or they can cause other diseases
which are pretty dangerous
but it's not all sad and sorrow after
all
and this particular research deals with
cancer cell lines which are cultured on
earth and then taken to space and
kept in the international space station
interestingly it has been noticed that
when these cancer cell lines are kept
in microgravity
they lose their potential of signaling
they stop signaling between one another
because there's no gravity to keep them
together most probably and they form
this sort of a spheroid which is called
a multicellular spheroid
they start rotating
and they lose their capacity of
signaling and this loss of signaling
potential stops metastasis metastasis is
that stage of cancer when the cancer
starts to spread from one particular
part of your body for example if you
have lung cancer and metastasis kicks in
it starts spreading all throughout your
body but it has been noticed that
microgravity acts as a boon or a gift
and
these cancer cells stop
proliferating and maybe this is the
beginning of something wonderful in the
domain of cancer medicine
and that's why you must have come across
the term space medicine a lot so space
medicine is not only something which
deals with taking care of astronauts and
protecting them from harm but also to
understand and analyze various treatment
technologies and methodologies about the
international space station use this
unique environment of space
and how can that be utilized and brought
back to earth for the better good of
each and every human beings on earth so
this is the reason why we are talking a
lot about space omics space omix is not
only a niche subject but it
has the potential to be
spread all over the world and to benefit
each and every human beings and if this
isn't interesting to you
then i don't know what is
now
i know
many of you
who are sitting today in the audience
are interested in getting involved in
astrobiology to get involved with some
great organization to do some
internships to
get a start in the career right so
here's a list of certain opportunities
that i'm going to talk about
which would definitely benefit you the
first one is the astrobiology
school which is known as red recon
exobiology full doctor on in french are
the exobiology school for
doctors doctorates for phd so this is an
opportunity for phds as well as some
master student as well who can
participate in the french exobiology
society's course and get involved with
great esa scientists that's european
space agency scientists i had the
opportunity to interact with them
one-on-one and get some vital insights
that's an amazing opportunity
then you also have blue marble space
institute of science which provides
young scientist program as well as
visiting scholar program opportunity
the young scientist program is for
bachelors
and the visiting scholars are for
masters and those who are beyond that
maybe you are pursuing a phd or postdoc
or you're a faculty or scientist you can
still join bmsis
as an associate research scientist
i will talk about
the criteria and the requirements to get
into it in a while
so you can also get involved in some
analog missions such as esep earth
science exploration program it was done
in ladakh and it is going to be done
over and over again so you would
definitely get the opportunity again
this is done
uh mainly by amity university of mumbai
the amity center of excellence in
astrobiology
then there's a lunaris
analog research station it's a moon
analog where you can spend a lot of time
do some experiments gain vital insights
some results
and the environment the feel is as if
you are on moon you can also get
involved in the european astrobiology
institute lc japan that's earth life
science institute
but more importantly you can also
showcase your projects showcase whatever
you have done and interact with some
great scientists
in conferences so there are a number of
conferences which are held every year
dedicated to astrobiology for example
i've grad e this is a conference for
astrobiology graduates
all over the world stu the students can
participate whether you are an
undergraduate student or a graduate
student whether you're doing your phd
you can participate here there are some
great keynote lectures by some great
astrobiologists so you can
listen to them get vital insights
interact with them and there's apps icon
which is
hosted by in collaboration with nasa
and it's a nasa funded conference so
this is going to be held in 2022 as well
so definitely check out apps icon and
appgrady and all of these institutes and
their opportunities now let me tell you
the major requirement to be a
participant in all of these events
so
all of these events as you might have
guessed requires you to be involved in
some sort of a project an astrobiology
or a space omix project
so that you
are excited you are interested but you
are going to
attend these
events to do something more right you
are not visiting a
tv show or
maybe some youtube video right you are
going to a conference or
an event so you are expected to do to do
something greater a little bit more than
what you have done so
doing a project at least starting a
project of your own is the
way to go is the first step that you
should take
and
here we are in biotech is gonna help you
to get started with your own
astrobiology or spaceonics project
and how and how to do that and what is
the procedure i'll talk in just a while
but before we move on let me give you an
overview of the career path to become an
astrobiologist suggested by nasa
so this is the most authentic data that
you can get right you don't have to
trust my words
you can believe what nasa has to say
but before i talk about this it would be
great if you can head over to the chat
section and
write down the level of education that
you are currently pursuing whether you
are a bachelor student or a master's
student or a phd student or you are a
postdoc
or you are a scientist
and it would be great if you can also
write down what's the subject that
you're studying
so that i can get an understanding of
what kind of audience i have
and
i would show you
that how whatever you are studying
whatever field you belong to
whichever
subject is your you are majoring in
right now
you still have a great chance to become
an astrobiologist and the career path is
pretty straightforward
so i can already see some great
responses i can see
yeah trying to interrupt in between
uh here to your question as well i had a
poll with me which i was supposed to
launch so it would be actually very
great if i just launch a poll and every
uh everyone could just uh board and tell
us to which different fields they belong
to and also what are their research
interests so this way we will uh
have
saved the different sorts of fields and
research interests of our participants
so my first question here is
what is your level of education are you
an undergraduate a graduate a
postgraduate or pursuing phd or done
with phd or a postdoc and also what are
your research interests omits spaceomics
infectious diseases or data science or
precision medicine or bioinformatics
using r and python or machine learning
and in the chat box uh you can feel free
to tell about which particular field or
degree you can see you belong to
over to yosho rajiv thank you i'll be
just closing this poll and
30 more seconds
awesome great thank you sonalika that
was
this is a great way to
learn your responses and understand you
to know you well
so it would be great if you can
go down to the poll and register your
answers
and
later on i would definitely
listen
more to your interests interact with you
answer your questions at the end of the
webinar and
maybe then we can discuss further so i
could see a lot of people who are
currently pursuing undergraduate they
are from biotech they are from pharma
they are from microbiology some are
masters some are phds and postdocs so
here is
your
career path as suggested by nasa
so
you are earning a degree right now right
so you are in this particular
domain and nasa says that you can earn a
degree in any field it can be physics
biology
oceanography
geology astronomy
definitely biology also includes medical
science and other sub domains
so
you are earning a degree
at the same time you are also building a
community
talking about the community of
astrobiologists you know since
astrobiology or space biology is still a
very new term
the community size is very small but
it's great to see that the number is
increasing today we have 77 people who
are enthusiastic about astrobiology here
there might be many more attending the
youtube live sessions many more people
who might not be able to have been able
to join because of the time zone
difference but they would definitely get
a recording of the video and so this
community is growing
and this is very important in your
journey
earning your degree and being a part of
a community so that you can interact
with people develop projects work on
them
and
understand how
an astrobiologist works so that's what
nasa says you do your graduate work
you
join various societies clubs or
organizations just like you are today
here at find vertex being one of those
organizations and you can earn your
doctorate that's a phd degree
look for funding opportunities
and there you are
you are almost there you are
now
having a fruitful career in astrobiology
i would give you a fun statistics today
i went over to linkedin i guess many of
you use linkedin if you don't please
make an account on linkedin and
feel free to connect with all of us and
we can chat and discuss more about space
online there so i've headed over to
linkedin and in the job section i looked
i filtered the search with astrobiology
at the time
and i came across around 20 jobs
available in the domain of astrobiology
in the
last 24 hours i guess which has been
posted so you can see
there's
a growing number of opportunities in the
domain of astrobiology and the people to
grab them are few
so this is your great opportunity
to make yourself
available make yourself aware and
kind of get your hands dirty in this
field so that you would be selected
above others and you can
begin your career in the domain of
astrobiology all right enough said
about career opportunities but
the
main question which comes up is how to
start working with the data that is
generated from the space flight missions
right
what is the mechanism or the methodology
to work with this data well that is
something which
this program is going to talk about and
we are going to hold your hand take you
step by step and
make you understand how to work with
this data
all of the projects all of the research
that we do at find biotech is
done on the server of mine biotic which
is called the server t bio info platform
i am going to give you a quick
overview of what this platform looks
like
and how you can work on this platform
right
so
um
if you can see my screen then
i think now you would be able to see my
screen
with the server t by info platform and
i would also
all right thank you navia
so there you go you have the link in the
chat section
so
head over to the link click on the link
go to this particular
page
you might get a prompt to sign up just
sign up using your email id or google
email id and you will get the
credentials to
use this pipeline in some time
and
now i would show you what this server
platform is all about so you know the
data that is generated from
any experiment be it a space related
experiment or a much focused biological
experiment it's huge in its volume
there's
big numbers of gigabytes involved so it
is not possible to analyze them on a
personal computer also if you would like
to
use your coding skills it would take 100
hundreds of lines of codes which is not
always a sweet spot for biologists right
so that's where find biotech server t
buying for platform makes things easier
for you
if you would look on my screen you would
see that there's various
categories in which the server is
divided you would find the ngs data mass
spectroscopy that's related to
proteomics structural biology data
integration and modeling which mainly
deals with machine learning algorithms
virology cancer biology
and a lot under the ngs data you would
see
there's transcriptomics
genomics epigenetics dna rna and
you see a lot of names right
so i'm gonna go ahead and show you how
these platform works
so if you look at transcriptomics the
first option is an rna-seq and there's a
drop down button if i click on here you
would get some demo pipelines so let me
click on one of the demo pipeline just
to give you an overview
so here's what the platform
looks like and all these names that you
can see here are basically the
algorithms which people use to analyze
the data sets
but to actually use this
algorithms in your computer using code
would be a very tedious task
but find biotech has made it easier for
you how much easy well as easy as just a
point and click
so it's it would just take you
a
click to use these high profile
algorithms to analyze your data and
that's not the end as you can see like
magic there are certain
algorithm names which are highlighted in
yellow so
this platform is ai enabled and it gives
you
a hint as to what would should be your
next algorithm in the process
so in a typical rnsc
uh pipeline
you have the next generation sequencing
data which is generated by the sequencer
you then do some pre-processing that is
cutting off the unwanted reads you can
see here it shows you how
you just chop it off which are
unnecessary
uh you also do some cleaning pcr
cleaning which are unwanted
then you go on to the next part which is
alignment
on the genome
then you form some
alternative splicing isoform
construction
to those people who for whom these
terms are pretty unfamiliar and new i
have a secret
tool for you and how you can actually
get hold of these terms
and not only that how can you also learn
to use this platform i would
tell you about that in just a second
so once you click on end and you make
like connect all the
required algorithms and a beautiful
visualization here by the way you get
that output since it's a demo pipeline
it generated the output right away but
if it would be a real pipeline which you
would use for your project it would take
a lot of time because it's
very server
loaded thing all right so these are the
various
results that are generated from the
pipeline what each of these means
is might be something which is new to
you but i would give you again
in a while
a trick how to understand that so may i
downloaded this particular file because
this is what i'm interested about
and here you
i have downloaded it you can see
i guess
um
just a second i will share my screen
well so that you can see it
all right so here you can see that the
data which i don't showed you has been
downloaded here
and then
i went on to
load this particular data in
an excel sheet here
so in this excel sheet you can see that
table says that there's group one of
certain samples and there's group two
and
what you can do is you can compare the
various genes and their expressions here
are the gene ids as you might say
so this is the entire
work or the research that people out
there do
but now as i promised i would show you
how you can learn about them
so if you go to the learn omixlogic
platform i'm sure you would get the link
in the chat section
you would get
various options here if you click on
courses
you would see there's various courses
just like sonalika mentioned in the
introduction part right
so here's an introduction to
bioinformatics there's bioinformatics
using python and various other courses
like genomics and transcriptomics if you
go down here you can see various
projects guided projects which you can
do just to get warmed up and here you
can also see the various types of
courses available
and once you go through these courses
you would get a better understanding of
what these data types are how to use
them what are the various algorithms
actually talking about
and that would make you ready for
the project that we usually do on this
platform and you can do as well so i
would also take this opportunity to show
you my own project that i did
in the domain of astrobiology so if you
go to the project section you see here
this is my project
i click on it it says the transcriptomic
analysis of dna damage response in
zebrafish embryos under simulated
microgravity i won't go into much detail
today because i would be doing that step
by step explaining every method and
step that i use to do this project in a
later session
but to give you an overview what i did
was i i investigated what is the effect
of simulated microgravity on zebrafish
and how that affects the dna damage
response and whether the damage that is
caused by microgravity and radiation
comparable similar or different and
that's what my project is you can
definitely check out my project on the
portal itself and read all about it so
if you go here you would also get access
to that data sets
then you can read the abstract here
understand what's the project all about
and why are we doing this it said in the
introduction section the methods those
who already are familiar with omics and
bioinformatics would definitely
understand the methods that i have used
here some of them are machine learning
algorithms some of them are not that
here's the results that has been
generated from all those
applications and tools and
the final part is how i interpret the
results that has been generated from the
pipelines and make a conclusion about
what i understand
from the data that is generated so
this is all about um the projects that
you can do here at binebiotics
uh server platform and
as you might have understood by now that
it is pretty much important to do to do
that to get your hands dirty to start
working on your own project right
because
that gives you an upper hand that gives
you an edge and that helps you to get
selected
in all those
opportunities so
here i would like to give you a small
overview of the program that we are
going to launch it would be a one month
program and it's divided into four parts
you can say
so first there would be interactive
sessions they would be usually one hour
live sessions with q a
they would be held on zooms on just like
today and there would be recorded
sessions available for those who
register and book their seats as well
and after you have done that
this is for the first time that i am
letting the cat out out of the bag that
there would be
a guest
special lecture by a guest faculty and
that person is an expert in this domain
he has he or she has been working in the
domain of space omix for quite a long
time and it's always a good idea to
learn from the best in the business so
stay tuned register yourself to get to
know who that special guest lecturer
would be and i am looking forward to
this session
pretty much
after you have done that after you have
gone through other courses after you
have attended the lectures you would get
an opportunity to start working on your
own project definitely you would get a
mentor support and
that would definitely be an amazing
thing which i'm looking forward to
because working on a project doing some
hands-on is the best thing that you can
do
for enhancing your education or
that's what i call as proper learning
and finally when you have done that you
have completed it congratulations you
have
gone through this hustle and finally
earned
your certificate you would get a
certified you would get certified by
prime biotic
and that would be a an amazing feather
to your hat added
so finally i would like to give you a
small overview of the one month program
and what we have in store for you the
first day would be an introduction to
astrobiology talking about what this
term means talking about origin of life
on earth the various extremophiles
we would also touch upon the debate of
iron a word versus dna world the tree of
life and it would be on 19th of october
on 25th of october we would
talk much more focused on origin of life
and evolution we would
talk about the great in endosame biases
theory we would show you how you can
work with data sets where you can find
those data sets and we would also give
talk to you about some project examples
of reconstructing ancient rna or ancient
protein using machine learning there has
been a lot of work which has been done
on a very popular protein which is
called rubisco to recreate it
reconstruct it understand how it evolved
and that gives us a better picture of
origin of life
then on first of november we would talk
specifically about space on mix and
astronaut health again taking the
reference of the nasa print study
digging in deeper understanding the
various environmental factors
understanding the various results of
this study
and it's
i will also show you how you can
retrieve the data and get ready for your
project
and
on the 8th of november
there will be one session which would
talk more about
the various
omics types which are required for space
omics and astronaut health
like genomics proteomics transcriptomics
metagenomics in general so that you have
a better picture of what we are dealing
with
and finally
on the 15th of november we would focus
on a case study of
a few projects including mine so i would
give you an overview step-by-step
analysis of my projects the methods that
i used and
the results and how to interpret them
so
that's all that i had for you today i
hope that you
got some insights into what we are
dealing with and why we are so much
hyped up about this particular field of
space science
and i hope that you liked the fact that
we are going to provide you an
opportunity to do your own project
so that you stand out from the crowd
so
i think that's all that i had for you
today but i will transfer the stage to
sonalika who would give you an overview
and a brief understanding of how you can
register and be a part of this program
and the other details
and also if you
have any questions
regarding space omics or astrobiology
feel free to put it down in the chat
section i would definitely answer them
over to you sonalika
thank you so much shubhrajee for such a
wonderful session and i'm here and i
mean it so i'm myself
information and none of the topics till
date has excited me so much but this
topic is like exciting me too and uh
trust me i'm going to be your first
student
you're most welcome i would be more than
happy to get you as my first student
and thank you so much okay so uh here is
the registration page uh yes
so uh could you please send the
link in the chat box michelle i just
pasted it here is the link to the
registration page and this registration
page has got all the information of all
the sessions that subrajit has discussed
till now right
uh here are the session details and also
the calendar accordingly the dates are
mentioned so you can see uh if the dates
are suiting you're not even if they are
not then we would definitely share the
recordings with you if you're a part of
the program so that's not a big deal and
now how do you register yourself so you
have three levels beginner intermediate
and advanced
based on uh the
prerequisites and the facilities that we
would be uh providing you and they have
been mentioned here so let's say if you
want to enroll for the beginner level
then you just have to click on select
option and proceed with the payment
checkout it's very easy very simple and
also we'll share the pre-registration
form with you so you can just register
your interest and as we are just
approaching the program it would be
starting on october 19th so it would be
great if you could just book your seat
right away before it gets late
and now as uh subrajeet has already told
you about the courses and how they have
arranged they are being arranged on the
portal i would just like to take you
through few of the
very introductory basic courses and also
there would be many people out here who
are also interested in different fields
as we saw on uh in the poll as well that
there are many people interested in
comics studies and analysis and also
data science
so let me just um
first of all go through this bytes and
molecules uh course that i was talking
about
uh towards the beginning of my
presentation so this course has got all
the introductory lessons mentioned for
different sorts of fields and if you're
interested let's say to learn about
precision medicine you can just begin
with first of all and getting an
understanding of what
precision medicine is what is the role
of bioinformatics and precision medicine
and then you can go ahead with uh taking
the specialization track or course for
precision medicine same goes for
genomics transcriptomic space omics and
then we have our and python languages as
well here for biomedical data analysis
and the best part uh about omex logic
that i personally like as well is that
it has got play a code playground now
when i say code playground let me just
show you along as well so you need not
install um r or like our studio or
jupyter notebooks or browse maybe but
you can actually practice the code here
in the console itself on the portal
right so let's just take one example
so here first of all you just go through
the basics the concepts get the
understanding
and then here you learn the code learn
the basics
and then you practice the code
right
and then you get to practice the code
run it and get your art books and that
is the way you learn about
different sorts of analysis using r and
same goes for python as well that you
can practice these codes here in the
console itself
and
then we have different sorts of
projects as well with us these are not
sample projects as you as you can see
here we have got a project on liver
cancer then we have
a project on covet a precision medicine
and then we have pdx project as well add
a number of more projects to which are
listed on the portal and you you can
just go the sign up is free and they
just go and explore these different
sorts of courses and projects which are
there on the portal and get your hands
on uh in the interested field of yours
and these projects they have a very
defined methodology of
what the analysis should be like and how
you have to proceed and then how you
have to run uh different sorts of
pipelines for different sorts of
analysis and then how you interpret the
results which you get from those uh
pipelines by running the pipelines
so that was what i wanted to share with
you and as subrajeet mentioned that
after like once the program is done then
after the program those who are
interested to carry out their own
independent research projects then we do
have research fellowship programs with
us where we have
either groups of students working on a
project or you can also work on an
independent project and go ahead with
your research and this all would be
under mental guidance
now if anyone has got any of the doubts
please mention in the chat box and also
i would be dropping my mail id that is
marketing at the rate fine dot bio or
you can also mail us at marketing at the
late at the rate omixlogic.com
and we would be happy to help you out
with any of the um
doubts or issues and once you are signed
up on the portal please make sure that
you have an updated profile now when i
say updated profile i mean that you
should have an updated profile picture
link in your uh or connect your social
accounts here facebook linkedin insta
and so on and then also have a brief bio
about yourself so that we know about you
and we would be monitoring your progress
at the back end from your profile itself
and you can uh just pick up the courses
that you would like to go through and
have them aligned under your profile
itself and once your courses are
complete you would be able to get the
certificates as well in your profile
now those who want to begin with an
understanding of omics let's say or data
science uh those are new to this field
uh you might be from biotechnology or
microbio or biochemistry or pharma as
well
and if you just want to begin with an
understanding of omics and data science
then you can go ahead with taking the
starter package let's say on the starter
subscription or the basic subscription
that's what we call it that is just
dollar 10 per month and under this
subscription you would be getting the
access to all the courses that are
mentioned here on the omixlogic portal
now when i say all the courses that
includes all the courses and the
projects the sample projects as well
which you can go through and learn from
all under dollar tech
so that is how you proceed and uh for
indian specifically if you face any of
the issues while passing through the
payment gateway then you can please mail
us we'll share uh the
uh banking details with you because we
don't want any interference in your
enrollment and it many times happens
that indians they face issues while
passing through the international
payment gateway
so please let there's no mailers in the
chat box and we'll be happy to help you
any questions
once taken beginner level subscription
can be upgrade yes haremi you can
definitely upgrade
and those who are interested i see a
question regarding research fellowship
program those who are interested to
enroll for a research fellowship program
they can definitely uh
join us for a research fellowship
meeting maybe and then um it would be
nice if you could share your mail id so
we have a short meeting tomorrow where
we will be discussing about this
research fellowship program because we
have some interested participants who
want to learn more about the program so
we kept a short meeting so those are
interesting they can let us
invite them
thank you so much everyone for joining
and it was very nice to have you all
here and thank you so much subrajeet and
dilara as well to uh guide us through
astro uh biology or space omex that's
for shogradjit likes to call it and we
would be looking forward to meeting you
all in the program uh just a second
ganeshka has a question would the
projects be hands on or we would just
get in uh the projects would be hands-on
so the the research fellowship programs
work in a way that you are first of all
supposed to complete the course material
have an understanding of how the server
could be used and how different
pipelines have to be done for different
sorts of data now once you have that
understanding how the pipe uh the
pipelines have to be run how the results
have to be interpreted after that you
are supposed to come up with a research
proposal right and once your research
proposal has been finalized our mentors
will definitely guide you to modify the
question if required at any uh sort of
uh point and also if you are not able to
come up with your own research proposal
by going to literature review then we
would definitely um offer you a few of
the
research questions or that you can job
like
be a part of the research projects that
we have already ongoing you can be a
part of those projects as well and once
your course review is done your
literature review is done your research
research proposal has been finalized or
you join a research project group then
we go forward with the actually doing
your research project that is we start
by looking for a data set and then how
do you normalize it and then how do you
run the pipelines get your result how
you interpreted it and finally uh your
publication so our
mentors will also help you edit your
manuscript and then go ahead with
publication so we we our mentors would
be there from the beginning till
then ganeshka i hope my
answer was able my like answer was clear
to you
uh
okay
thank you so much navia for sharing in
all our social uh links so you can join
us on social uh accounts linkedin
facebook and slack is uh
the most common communication
uh way where we actually stay connected
so we have slack groups with each and
every program where we just post the
session links and recordings and also
you would be able to find the session
links zoom links there was a person
asking about the zoom link so we post
the zoom links on the program page and
the program page could be assessed by uh
only the participants of the program
and uh yes be a part of a whatsapp group
as well so that you can
stay updated with all our upcoming
programs and webinars
okay so now i would be ending the
meeting thank you everyone for joining
and
being a part of this webinar we are
looking forward to your participation in
the program thank you so much bye bye
take care